[Music]
George Sarris is a billionaire but
somehow his own money isn't enough to
fund the totality of his anti-american
agenda so US taxpayers had to step into
the breach and help as well and they did
Department of Justice documents newly
obtained by Judicial Watch thank heavens
show that in 2016 the Obama
administration whose misdeeds are now
just coming to light gave almost nine
million dollars to support something
called the east-west Management
Institute that's a service funded
venture according to the Judicial Watch
the money did little other than empower
the socialist government of Albania
which spends a lot of time making its
people more miserable tom Fitton is the
president of Judicial Watch and he joins
us tonight one of the reasons I'm so
glad you're here tom is because you kind
of tie a bow on stories about
ministrations over but there's a lot
that they did that we don't know
anything about because the press refused
to cover those stories tell us this
small piece of it what did they do in
Albania and why well they're supporting
the socialist communist government
they're the source operations and
they're doing it with taxpayer dollars
they were doing it in 2016 and they were
even doing it in the first part of the
Trump administration in 2017
co-sponsoring surveys of the population
that generated ninety-one percent of the
support in favor of the pro-government
ProSource operation that would have
restricted the Independence of the
judiciary you know like all strongman
governments they don't like independent
judiciaries so they were trying to
reform the judiciary in a way that would
have brought it under control the
socialist government there and what's
troubling is that obviously Soros needs
no tax payer money to do any of this
advocacy work but the State Department
and USAID is partnering with Soros and
basically allowing Soros to set our
foreign policy agenda and then secondly
Soros his operations according to these
documents were allowed to come in to the
State Department and provide technical
reviews of other applications for other
government money in Albania but I mean
George Soros hates the United States and
I'm judging that by the projects that he
funds all of which are designed to
change the country as it is now or
deport US interests so why in the world
would any State Department gave money to
a Soros Fund
operation well it's not only in Albania
we have four at four lawsuits at one
point Albania Romania he's active in
Hungary Guatemala Colombia they're very
very active and it doesn't take a lot of
money to have a big impact in these
countries and the governments are under
assault from the Soros State Department
unity effort to bring socialism and stop
anything in the area of reform
constitutionalism the sort of things
that Americans would be comfortable with
the Soros groups aren't and you know
look he's billionaire he doesn't need
the money and when you fund them in one
place it means he has more money to
spend elsewhere
so if you don't like what Soros is doing
here at home you should know it's being
indirectly subsidized thanks to the
State Department in USAID at least as
early as at least as soon as long ago as
2006 so our else is getting State
Department money Planned Parenthood
which is arm in the Democratic Party
gets a half a billion a year in taxpayer
funds
is there any right of center or
pro-american group that gets any
taxpayer funding of any kind well I
think most of them don't think to ask
for it but certainly the State
Department is not terribly interested in
funding groups that are antagonistic to
their agenda abroad and this is kind of
another way for the State Department to
stick it to the Trump administration
because some of this activity was taking
place in early 2017 again attacking the
idea of an independent judiciary in
Albania it's this is your tax dollars at
work and we had to sue to get the
records the more you know the more
appalling it is and thank you for
bringing this light I appreciate it
you're one bit